انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
مدن ايران تنتفض بالاضراب والغربي يقلل من
خطوه طهران حلا شرطه الاخلاق اما الحرس
الثوري في يهدد المحتجين
الحرب تجتازوا حدود اوكرانيا بعد ضرب
مسيرتين لقاعدتين روسيتين وموسكو تردوا
بقصف
يعني اذا كان
يؤكد في مقابله خاصه
لم يتجاوز احدا وهو مفتوح لكافه القوى
السياسيه
تقترب من حجز مقعد في ربع نهائي كاس
العالم على حساب كوريا الجنوبيه
اذا والنتيجه حتى الان اربع مقابل صفر
لصالح البرازيل ومنتخب الساموراي يودع
[موسيقى]
وسعيدهم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
في ايران يبدو ان حل شرطه الاخلاق لم يحل
من عزم المتظاهرين على الاكمال بما بداوه
منذ اكثر من شهرين فبوصلته المحتاجين هي
حل النظام لا حلوا شرطه الاخلاق دعوات
الاضراب هذه تزيد من مخاوف السلطات
الايرانيه بعدين ادى الدعوات مماثله
لتعبئه المحتاجين في الاسابيع الماضيه الى
زياده الاحتقان الشعبي بحسب صحيفه
الجاردينيا واليوم تجددت الاحتجاجات في
مختلف المدن الايرانيه لتشمل نحو 80% من
الاسواق والبازارات الى جانب المصانع مع
تجدد كل اضراب لا تتغيروا اساليب النظام
الايراني اذكد الحرس الثوري ان القوات
الامن لم ترحم ما اسمتهم بمطيري الشغب
وقطع الطرق والارهابيين وفقا ما نقلته
وكالته تسنيم الايرانيه كما نقلت ايران
انترناشونال عن رئيس السلطه القضائيه حسين
قوله ان بعض المتظاهرين بتهمه الحرابه
التي يترتب عليها حكم الاعدام
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا الاحتجاجات مستمره في ايران
شهدوا معنا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا قبل
قليل الى غرفه الاخبار في العربيه
لمظاهرات ليليه ايرانيه في مدينه مشهد هذه
المره هذه المظاهرات المستمره اذا في
ايران منذ اكثر من شهرين بعد مقتل مهس
اميني ورغم ما اعلنه النظام او مسؤول في
النظام الايراني يوم امس همم من ان هناك
قرارا بحل شرطه الاخلاق والتي توفيت على
يدها الشابه الكرديه في سبتمبر الماضي
ماسا اميني بسبب عدم تقيدها بضوابط اللباس
التي تفرضها هذه الشرطه الاخلاق في ايران
ورغم الاعلان انه سيتم حل هذه الشرطه شرطه
الاخلاق الا ان المظاهرات كما تشاهدون هي
ما تزال مستمر وفي اتساع في عموم المناطق
الايراني
والنظام الايراني باتي محاصرا في حلقه
مفرغه بحسب تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين
واجانب جامعتها صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه
الحلقه المفرغه هذه هو بحسب الجارد تدفع
البلاد الى مزيد من العزله الدوليه مهما
حاولت ايران تخلص منها المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص ربمالي كان له التصريح الابرز اذ
قال ان واشنطن تركز على قرار تسليح روسيا
في اوكرانيا وقمع احتجاجاتها الداخليه
اكثر من تركيزها على محادثات التي احياء
الاتفاق النووي مؤكدا ان العرض التالي
للتضامن الامريكي مع المحتجين من المرجح
ان ياتي عندما تقدم واشنطن اقتراحا
باستبعاد ايران من لجنه الامم المتحده
المعنيه بوضع المراه في تصويت المقرر يوم
الرابع عشر من ديسمبر وفي سياق المتصل او
ردت الصحيفه البريطانيه ان دبلوماسيين
اوروبيين يرون ان القياده الايرانيه وصلت
الى نقطه تحول لا رجعه فيها وان النظام
الايرانيه يعيش تحت ضغوط السبل المثلى
للتعامل مع الاحتجاجات
صارديه
[موسيقى]
متحدث باسم وزاره
الغاء شرطه الاخلاق في معتبر برلين ان
الغاء الشرطه الاخلاق في ايران لا يؤثر
على تعبئه الايرانيين من اجل حقوقهم
الاساسيه فقالت منطقه باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الالمانيه ان الايرانيين
والايرانيات ينزلون الى الشارع للدفاع عن
حقوقهم الاساسيه وانهم يريدون العيش بحريه
واستقلاليه مشدده ان هذا الاجراء في حاله
تطبيقه لن يغير شيئا حسب قوله
معنى من واشنطن الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات حسين عبد الحسين استاذ حسين
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
ما الذي يمكن ان يغير من طريقه تعاطي
النظام الايراني مع الاحتجاجات الداخليه
اعتقد انه نحن راينا بعض التراجع او
التغيير يتمثل ب بالون الاختبار الذي
اطلقه النظام الايراني والذي قال فيه انه
طيب سنه تراجع عن موضوع الحجاب ولكن عندما
راى انه يعني هذا تصريح من هذا النوع لم
ينهى الاحتجاجات تراجع عن عن هذا التصريح
اعتقد انه هو في ازمه يعني صار واضحه ان
هو في ازمه وصار واضحه انه يعني حتى لو
زاد منسوب العنف والقمع او حتى لو اصدر
قاعد يعني احكام بالاعدام اكثر بحق
المتظاهرين والمتظاهرات لا يبدو انه هذه
الوسائل تجدي حتى الان نعم طيب استاذ حسين
برايك ما الذي يدفع المتظاهرين للاستمرار
في الاحتجاج رغم الاعلان عن حل شرطه
الاخلاق يعني التي كانت المتسببه في همم
مقتل امين همم يعني لماذا يستمر
المتظاهرون في الذهاب ابعد في مطالبهم
كذلك
وكلنا نعرف انه مقتل ماسه امينه كان
الشراره التي اولعت الاحتجاجات ولكن
الاحتجاجات اوسع من ذلك بكثير وهي لم تكن
المره الاولى بل هذه هي المره الاطول
والتي يبدو فيها الايرانيون اكثر اصرارا
على الاطاحه بالنظام نفسه في المرات
الماضيه يعني حاولوا وكان هناك عنف وتراجع
ولكن هذه المره يعني هذه اطول فتره
اعتراضات ضد النظام الايراني منذ الثوره
الايرانيه على نظام الشاه
فيعني اعتقد انه هذه هذا الموضوع اكبر
بكثير من امي واكبر بكثير من موضوع الحجاب
لانه يشمل كل المواضيع وخصوصا طبعا في
الاساس همم الاقتصاد الايراني المتهاوي
بشكل كبير ولذلك نرى انه البازار يعني
تجار ايران هؤلاء اصلا هم اعمده النظام
القائم نرى ان هؤلاء يشاركون في الاضراب
وهذا ما يضع النظام في وضع همم خارج اكثر
من الوضع الذي كان يجد بصوا قبل اسابيع او
حتى قبل شوي ما رايك يعني النظام يقول ان
هذه الاحتجاجات هي مؤامره غربيه وبعنا
مدعومه من الخارج فحين ان المحتاجين يرون
انه هناك همم دعم غير كافي من المجتمع
الدولي لهذه الاحتجاجات برايك ما المقاربه
اللانجع التي يمكن للمجتمع الدولي ان
ينتهجها من اجل دعم المحتاجين في ايران
انا طبعا اصدق ال- محتاجين الايرانيين ولا
اصدق النظام واعتقد انه هم على حق لا يوجد
دعم دول كافه والدعم الدولي طبعا نحن لا
نتحدث يعني لا عن سلاح ولا عن اموال عن اي
شيء نحن نتحدث عن مواقف حماسيه هناك خجل
الدبلوماسي دولي وسبب هذا الخجل ان هناك
حيره انه في حال انهار النظام الايراني ما
الذي سيكون البديل وهنك الخاص ان يكون
هناك سيناريو العراق وافغانستان وما شابه
ذلك هذه العوامل تدفع المجتمع الدول
وخصوصا عواصم قرار الكبرى في الغرب تدفع
الى التردد والى اصدار تصاريح دعم ولكن لا
نرى يعني
لا نرى انه حتى الان هناك فعليا محاوله
انقضاض دبلوماسيه على الاقل على النظام
الايراني ودفعه يعني الى تغيير الفعلي او
التراجع امام الطالب شكرا جزيلا لك من
واشنطن الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه حسين عبد الحسين
[موسيقى]
اذهب الى الحرب الالكترونيه
في مقاطعه ريان وسيراتوف الروسيتين وقالت
الدفاع الروسيه
حاول توجيهي ضربات ضد مطار دبي
ومطار اجلس في مقاطعه باستخدام طائرات
المسيره صوفيا الصنع
في صباح اليوم الخامس من ديسمبر الجاري
قام النظام كيف بهدف تعطيل الطائرات
الروسيه بعيده المدى بمحاولات هجوم
بمسيرات على المطارات العسكريه
الطائره بدون طيار الاوكرانيه التي كانت
تحلق على ارتفاع المنخفض تم اعتراضها من
قبل الدفاع الجوي الروسي
[موسيقى]
الى المشاهدين ان نبقى عيوننا على تظاهرات
الايرانيه التي ما تزال مستمره وصور جديده
اذا وصلتنا للتو اذا من حي استرخان في
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران التي تستمر فيها
هذه الاحتجاجات الليليه كذلك والاضرابات
في عديد الاسواق والمزارات نستمع قليلا
الى تافهات المحتاجين في طهران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تشاهدون هذه الصور من حيث ستار خان في
العاصمه طهران هناك على ما يبدو ااا اشعال
ااا اطار مطاطي وهوتات كذلك مستمره رغم ما
اعلنه مسؤول في النظام الايراني عن حل
شرطه الاخلاق التي تسببت في مقتل الشابه
الايرانيه مهسا اميني في سبتمبر الماضي
افاد مراسل العربيه باستمرار القصف
الاوكرانيه على مدينه دمياط مخلفا اربعه
قتلى حتى الان كما تم قصف المدينه بصواريخ
جراد فيما تحدث مسؤول الاوكراني عن
انفجارات في خارف جراء قصف الروسيه بصورخ
كنوز واقله مصادر اوكرانيه الى روسيا قصفت
بشكل مكثف المناطق عده في البلاد مشيرتان
الى انقطاع الكهرباء والمياه عن عده مدن
بسبب القصف الروسي وقد طالبت رئاسه
الاوكرانيه المواطنين بالنزول الى الملائع
بسبب القصف الروسيه افادت رويترز بضرب
صواريخ الروسيه لمحطات طاقه في صومي شمال
شرق اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
زهره رئيس الروسي القديمه جسر القرم الذي
دمر جزئيا في اكتوبر في اول زياره له الى
شبه الجزيره التي ضمتها موسكو عام 2014
منذ بدء الهجوم على اوكرانيا وظهر بوتين
يقود سياره على الجسر الذي يربط بين شبه
جزيره القرمونيه والاراضي الروسيه
وتضرر الجسر في اكتوبر انفجار قويا نسبته
السلطات الروسيه الى القوات الاوكرانيه
وللحرب في اوكرانيا تابعات جما منها
الداخليه واخرى خارجيه الجديد تقارير
تتحدث ان حرب اوكرانيا ساهمت بزياده
مبيعات الاسلحه عالميه هيئه لمراقبه
مبيعات الاسلحه الدوليه اشارت الى ان
مبيعات الاسلحه العالميه زادت بنحو اثنين
في المئه في عام 21 وهو العام السابع على
التوالي من الزياده واضافت الهيئه ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا ادت الى زياده الطلب
على الاسلحه هذا العام لكن الصراع قد يؤدي
ايضا الى تحدي العرض لاسباب ليس اقلها ان
روسيا مورد الرئيسي للمواد الخام
المستخدمه في انتاج الاسلحه
السلام قال ان ذلك قد يعطل الجهود في
الولايات المتحده اوروبا لتعزيز قوتهما
المسلحه والتجديد مخزناتهما بعد ارسال
ذخيره ومعدات اخرى بمليارات الدولارات الى
اوكرانيا
في اثناء اعلن اليوم عن تشكيل قوه اقليميه
لحفظ السلام من قبل قادتي دول غرب افريقيا
الهدف من هذه القوه التدخل ضد المتشددين
والانقلابات كالتي شهدتها المنطقه في
العامين الماضيين قرروا التشكيل القوه
الاقليميه جاء بعد رصد مراقبين مكمنا
للخطر يتمثلوا في سوق سوداء للسلاح خلفتها
الحرب في اوكرانيا تستفيد منها الجماعات
الارهابيه في افريقيا لاسيما في منطقه
الساحل التي تمتلك منافذ اوروبا و سابقا
اعربت قوى الغربيه عن مخاوفها من احتمال
التسرب السلاح الذي يتم ضخمه الى اوكرانيا
الى عصابات التهريب ومن ثم الى عصابات
اجراميه وحركات ارهابيه
لصحيفه الفرنسيه فان العواصمه الغربيه
تشعر بالقلق من احتمالات تهريب بعض
الاسلحه الى قوى اخرى غير الجيش الاوكراني
ومن بين تلك الاسلحه الصواريخ
معنى من باريس المحلل والخبير العسكري عبد
الناصر العائد استاذ عبد الناصر اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه كيف يصل
هذا السلاح من اوكرانيا التي فيها حرب الى
دول غرب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
هذه هذه الشبكات يعني راسيخه وقديمه جدا
وتعمل في التهريب لكن المخاوف الغربيه
بالواقع ليست يعني هي من ال همم من من
اوكرانيا او من الجيش الاوكراني ال-
المخاوف الغربيه هي من المنظمات الروسيه
همم هناك منظمات شبه عسكريه روسيه همم
لديها تاريخ طويل
بتهريب الاسلحه وبنقلها منذ انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيات السابقه وهذه ال- ال-
المنظمات مثل فاكنار لديه الان موجود راسك
في عموم افريقيا همم روسيا يمكنها ان يعني
او هددت ولمحت باستمرار الى امكانيه
استخدام همم او قلب المعادله في اوكرانيا
باستخدام
الدعم الغربي
يعني تمرير هذه الجزء من هذه الاسلحه التي
يعني عليها علامات ارقام
معروف انها تتبع لروسيا انت تقصد هنا انه
همم
الروس هم الذين يرسلون الاسلحه من
اوكرانيا يعني الاسلحه الغربيه التي
يرسلها الغرب الى الاوكرانيين ينقلها
الروس الى افريقيا
المخاوف الغربيه
بشكل واضح انه هذه الاسلحه خاصه يعني يشار
بالدرجه الاولى الصواريخ السنجر المضاده
للطائرات صحيح انه هذه قد تقع في ايدي
عصابات ارهابي همم الجهاز الغربيه تفسر
هذا التهديد على انه روسيا طبعا الحصول
على الاسلحه بميدان المعركه سهل جدا يعني
كل المناطق التي احتلها الروس موجود فيها
بقايا اسلحه انه يتم تمرير عدد من قطع هذا
السلاح الى جهات ارهابيه
وتقوم باستخدامه ضد الطيران المدني هذا
هذا اكبر فعلا وهذه مساله خطيره جدا
ونتذكر مثلا عندما نقول نتذكر حرب
افغانستان وكيف كان همم يعني همم لهذه
الصواريخ دور حاسم في تلك الحرب ما هي
المخاطر يعني ماذا يمكن ان يحدث اذا ما
صحت هذه التوقعات وهذه التقارير عن نقل
هذه الاسلحه الى دول الغرب القاره
الافريقيه ما هي اكبر المخاطر او اسوء
السيناريوهات
اسواق السيناريوهات تعرض الطيران المدني
لهذه الطائرات هذه الصواريخ يعني تصطاد
الطائره المدنيه بمنتهى السهوله بمنتهى
البساطه وتسقط اي طائره مجانيه ويعني في
حال يعني لا سمح الله حدث حدث مثل هذا من
هذا النوع في المستقبل سيكون يعني صدى سيء
جدا سلبي جدا في الغرب انه هي قدمت هذه
الاسلحه بطريقه عشوائيه وغير منظمه وغير
مضبوطه وبالتالي تسربت حتى لو كان من خلال
الروس يعني تسربت لجهه ارهابيه ما
واستخدمتها ضد طائره مدنيه في اي مكان
بالعالم
المخاوف الغربيه الحقيقه هي نجمه من هذه
التهديد الروسي الداعم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
همم عبد الناصر العائد المحلل هو الخبير
العسكري كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
عقبات كثيره تحيط بانشاء محكمه خاصه
في قفص الاتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي اقترح
العمل
المتحده لملاحقه ما اسمتها بالجرائم
الروسيه غير ان اسئله جديه تطرح حول جدول
مثل هذه المحكمه وما اذا كانت ستنتهي
بمحاكمه الكرملين او كبار المسؤولين
العسكريين وتتمثل الاولى العقبه في انشاء
مثل هذه المحكمه التي تتطلب دعنا دوليا
حرب تشنج في اوروبا اما تحدي الثاني فيبرز
في توقيف مشتبهم بهم حيث تقتصر جريمه
العدوان على كبار المسؤولين في روسيا فيما
من المرجحي ان يكون بوتن وكبار المسؤولين
في مامن من الاعتقال والمحاكمه على الاقل
اثناء وجودهم في المنصب وربما حتى بعد ذلك
تحت شعار
[موسيقى]
نصب مئات اللاجئين اخي من في شارع يقع بين
متحف اللوفر ومجلس الدوله في فرنسا في
خطبه غير مسبوقه من حيث رمزيه المكان الذي
اختاروه ويطالب هؤلاء بتامين ماوى عاجل
لهم مع بدء موجه برد قارسا في العاصمه
باريس
اعداد كبيره
المتزايد والسكان الذين يقولوا بعضهم ان
تواجد اللاجئين هنا يخلوا بالنظام العام
وبالامن احيانا والجمعيات الحقوقيه
والمنظمات الانسانيه التي تقول انه من دون
ايجاد لهؤلاء فانهم سيواصلون المبيته في
الشارع اما الجهه الرابعه فهي الدوله حيث
تتقاذف الجهات الامنيه والقضائيه
والاداريه والبلديه كره تتحمل المسؤوليته
عن الوضع القائم
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
البرهان يؤكد في مقابله خاصه للعربيه ان
الاتفاق الايطالي لم يتجاوز احدا وهو
مفتوح لكافه القوى السياسيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد ابتداء من اليوم دخل
القرار الاوروبي بتحديد سعر النفط
الروسيان لكنه سامح به فتره الانتقاليه
للدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
وهي ثلاث دول اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
تعتمد بشكل خاص على خط انابيب النفط من
روسيا بسبب موقعها الجغرافي وعدم قدرتها
على استبدال الواردات بسرعه وفي الوقت
ذاته فقد دخل تحدي في اسعار النفط الروسيه
ايضا بموجب بهذا السقف فان تقديم خدمات
غربيه
عن طريق البحر هو امر محظور حاله بيع
النفط فوق حاجز الستين دولارا للبرميل
قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا بوضع سقفا لسعر
النفط الروسي همم قفز الاسعار النفط بنسبه
2% خصوصا بعد ان ابقى الدول اوف كلانس على
اهدافها المتعلقه بالانتاج
[موسيقى]
روسيا رفضت وضع سعر لخامها واكدت انها
بحاجه الى تحليل الموقف لكن كيف ستتحول
وجهات روسيا في نقل النفط صدرات موسكو
مشاهدين النفطيه المنقوله بحرا الى القاره
الاسيوي اصلا ارتفعت بالنسبه 31 في المئه
على اساس السنويه في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه وفي العام الحالي مثل الخمر
الروسيه 22% من الواردات الصين وثلاثه عشر
بالمئه من واردات الهند ونحو 5% من واردات
تركيا
هذا يعني في المقابل انا الدول الثلاث
استحوذت على ما يزيد قليلا عن اربعين في
المئه من اجمالي الصادرات النقيه الروسيه
لكن تم مشكله ستطغى على الشحن الروسي مع
تقلص الاسطول المتاح للنقل نفطها مع خساره
السفن الاوروبيه فعاده ما يستغرق نقل
النفط الخام من بحر البلطيق الى الهند ما
لا يقل عن اربعه اضعاف مده نقل الشحنات
الى روتردام
وستجد روسيا نفسها كذلك مضطره لمضاعفه عدد
السفن للتسليم بالكميات والمواعيد المتفق
عليها محللون يقولون ان روسيا ممكن ان
تلجا لوسائل اخرى مثل نقل النفط من سفينه
الى اخرى لاخفاء اصولها وخلط مثلها بانواع
اخرى للالتفاف على الحطره
معنى من موسكو الدكتوره لانا بدفان
الباحثه في العلاقات الدوليه في مدرسه
الاقتصاد العليا دكتوره نانا اهلا بك معنا
بدانا نلمس ارتفاعا في اسعار النفط باثنين
بالمئه ما هي التوقعات اللي انعكاس دخول
هذا القرار الاوروبي حيز تنفيذ تسقيف سعر
النفط الروسي ب 60 دولار للبرميل
البرميل
ليس فقط الاوروبيه انما اقتصادات العالميه
وخاصه الدول التي تنتج نفسها مثل هذا
القرار هو يؤذي الدول الكثير من الدول
وليس فقط همم
ان يكون هناك تخفيض العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالتالي
هذا القرار لم ياتي باي نتائج ايجابيه على
الصعيد العالمي وعلى الصعيد الاقتصادات
الدول النفسيه ثانيا بالتاكيد بدانا نلموس
ومع الايام قد نشاهد ان البرميل الواحد
يساوي تكلفته 100$ بالتالي الاسعار سوف
تزداد اكثر ومساله اتضخم الاقتصادات سوف
تزداد بشده متى تتوقعين يمكن ان يصل سعر
البرميل الى عتبه ال 100$
بالتاكيد مع الايام القادمه والاسابيع
القادمه ولكن اعتقد بان هذا القرار تحديد
سقف الاسعار وفقط لمده شهرين اي بالتالي
لربما الاتحاد الاوروبي قد يعيد صياغه هذا
القرار او تلغيه او ان يحدث سعر سعر جديد
الروسي بالتالي هذا القرار هو ليس قرار
دائم او قرار مقيد غير خاضع للتعديل انه
بتعليقه يمكن تعديله ولكن هذه الفتره هي
الفتره الشهرين مراقبه هل يمكن ان ينجح
القرار او ان لكن بالتاكيد كان هناك عده
اراء اوروبيه مخالفه لهذا القرار ووضحت
بان هذا القرار قد ساهم في زياده العب على
الاقتصادات ولن يحل مساله العسكريه روسيا
قالت انها يعني حتى لو مثلا متعلقه بشهرين
فقط لكن روسيا قالت انها لم تبعه النفط
لاي دوله تفرض سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي هل
حقا روسيا قادره على الاستغناء عن هذه
الاسواق وقادره على كيف تعويض خسائرها
الان
اساسيه بالنسبه للانقلات البحريه حوالي
31% اليوم الصادرات الى الصين تبلغ نسبه
نسبه كبيره يعني 31
23 عفوا بالمئه مقارنه تنبي الصادرات التي
كانت تعطيها روسيا بالنسبه 21% بالتالي
اصبحت الصين الان بديل عن قاره الاوروبيه
كمساله اقتصاديه بينها وبين الجانب الروسي
وايضا الهند وحتى تركيا
من حدد السعر الثقفي ومن سوف يعاني
اقتصاده بالتالي ايطالي لم توافق على هذا
القرار سوف تستكمل روسيا التعامل معها صرب
يا ايضا بالتالي هذا القرار يخضع فقط
للدول المتشدده في العقوبات على روسيا
والتي حددت سعر الصرف لدى روسيا الاسواق
جديده وايضا ارباح جديده لم نلاحظ بين انك
الكاس في الاقتصاد الروسي على السريع
المواد البتروليه وايضا روسيا تسعى الان
الى تخفيض انتاجها نحن نعلم ان روسيا ما
كنتش حوالي مليون و850 برميل اي تخصير
الانتاج يصل الى فقط مليون برميل بالتالي
روسيا لم تعاني من ايدي كاسات وايضا من
سيعاني بهذا التخفيض قرار الروسي فقط
الاقتصادات الاوروبيه وايضا هناك نقطه
مهمه بان المنظمه اوبك لم ترحب بهذا
القرار لا يوجد بديعه مواد البتروليه
الروسيه حتى لم توافق ايضا
وصلت الفكره لنا بدفان الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه في مدرسه الاقتصاد العليا من
موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى السودان وبعد عام من الازمات
وقعت القوى السياسيه السودانيه على
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يهدف الى حل الجمود
السياسيه في البلاد حضر التوقيع ممثلين عن
الاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي والامم
المتحده والاليه الثلاثيه واللجنه
الرباعيه بنود الاتفاق الايطاليه على
تنظيم الانتخابات في نهايه الفتره
الانتقاليه المحدده بعامين والتي تبدا منذ
لحظه تعيين رئيس الوزراء الاتفاقنا ايضا
على التاكيد على الجيش الوطني الموحد
ومهني ويكون رئيس الدوله القائد العام
للجيش ومن ابرز بنود الاتفاق الايطاليه
السوداني اطلقوا عمليه شامله لكشف الجرائم
ومحاسبه مرتكبها
هذا واقال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الاتفاق الايطالي الذي
تم توقيعه لن يتجاوز احدا مشيرا الى ان
الجميع في السودان يسعى لحدوث توافق داخل
مختلف القوى السياسيه والعسكريه
لم يتجاوز احد حتى الان وهو مفتوح
ولكن
قضايا نحن نسعى لحدوث توافق اذا كان همم
داخل القوى السياسيه او داخل القوى
السياسيه والعسكريه همم
لكمال هذا التوافق بين هذه المجموعات ونزع
الاستكمال التوقيع القوه التي نرى انها
ضروريه ان تكون موجوده في ساحه السياسيه
داخل قبه القصر الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
التام الفاعلون في المشهد السياسي من اجل
التوقيع على اتفاق الاقاريا ينص على اقامه
سلطه مدنيه بالكامل في كافه مستوياتها
السياديه والتنفيذيه والتشريعيه والتاكيد
على جيش المهني الواحد وملتزم بالعقيده
العسكريه الموحده
حضور دولي واقلي شهد حفل مراسم التوقيع
الذي جدد فيه البرهان التاكيد على خروج
الجيش من معادله السلطه وسياسه يؤكد
التزامنا على خروج المؤسسه العسكريه من
العمليه السياسيه نهائيا
هذا الامر
يجب ان يصاحبه خروج القوى السياسيه من
المشاركه في مرحله التقليه
استجابه لمطلب الثوار
ما هذا لعوده المسار الديمقراطي في
السودان وقريبا ستبدا المرحله الاهم ان
شاء الله المرحله الثانيه نبدا فورا
بالمؤتمرات والورش يعني مناقشه القضايا
الاربعه والخمسه الان تحتاج الى تفاصيل
وتحتاج الى عمل جاد لكي نصل للاتفاق
النهايه خلال اربع اسابيع ان شاء الله
الاتفاق الايطالي سيبقى مفتوحا لاستيعاب
القوى المدنيه
المتحفظه على بنوده وستجر عمليات مشاورات
من اجل تطويره الى اتفاق النهائي
بتيسير من قوى دوليه واقليميه
في تشجيع الاطراف السودانيه
للحوار والوصول الى ما وصلوا اليه في هذه
المرحله ومازلنا نواصل هذا الاتجاه
لان موقف المملكه العربيه السعوديه هو
تحقيق الاستقرار ووحده السودان والازدهار
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي وقع في الخرطوم
بالرغم من انه حاضيه بمباركه دوليه
واقليميه الا ان البعض يقول انه قد يواجه
تحديات على الارض في ظل رفض بعض القوى
السياسيه وبعض لجان المقاومه
لجان المقاومه ارسلت رسائلها سريعا
بالخروج الى الشارع وعلى بعد كيلومترات
قليله من القصر الرئاسي اتجاه التنسيقيه
لجان المقاومه لتعبر عن رفضها للاتفاق
تعاملت معهم الشرطه بالغاز المثيل للدموع
وذلك يشكل استمرارا لمشهد يبدو ان سحب
ازماته لم تنشع حتى الان محمد عثمان
العربي الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
في تونس توقف موزع الادويه بالجمله عن
النشاط وقرروا عندما نقل الادويه من
المعامل ومن الصيدليه المركزيه الى
الصيدليات في مختلفه انحاء تونس يقولون ان
قرارهم هذا تم اتخذه اجباريا بسبب غياب
الامكانيات لمواصله العمل وان مؤسساتهم
مهدده بالافلاس وتفتقر لمخزون ادويه بسبب
عدم تجديد السلطات شهاده خصم من المورد
للمؤسسات الموزعه للادويه بالجمله على
مبيعات الادويه لعام 2022
يحثوا محرز الخطى امام مستشفى الاطفال
بتونس العاصمه لاخذ الدواء اللازم لزوجته
وابنته حديثه الولاده وبعد طول انتظار
يعود بيد فارغه واخرى لا شيء فيها عليه ان
يبحث عن الدواء في الصيدليات الخاصه لعله
تونس احنا كل شيء مش موجوده بتشوف ازمه
فقدان الادويه في تونس تتعمق اكثر خاصه مع
توقفي موزعي الادويه بالجمله عن نقل
الادويه في مختلف انحاء البلاد باستثناء
الضروريه منها بعد خلاف مع السلطات حول
نسب الارباح ما يعني توقف تزويد الصيدليه
بنسبه 99%
ايقاف هذا بشيء اكثر تدريجيا على عمليه
التزاوج بتاع صيدليات اليوم مش نحسه شويه
الازمه هديه لكن معه الايام القادمه جدا
توقف هو موزعين الادويه بالجمله عن النشاط
يمثل ضربه مذيعه اخرى للقطاع الصحي المثقل
بمشاكلها هيكليه واخرى مستجده هكذا يؤكد
متابعون مع تصاعد التحذيرات من احتقان
الوضع الاجتماعي جراءه توتر الاضرابات في
قطاعات حيويه وحساسه ما قد يهدد السينما
الاجتماعي
الا بعد اتفاق السلطات مع موازيعي الادويه
لانضاف الى اضرابات اخرى بعد توقف في لغه
الحوار بين الحكومه واتحاد الشغل في
قطاعات النقل والمخابز والكهرباء والتعليم
وغيرها الوضع الاجتماعي خطير يقول متابعون
تم التغيير حقيقي داخل المجتمعات تونسي
اليوم ليس فقط اتحاد الشغل من يقود
الاضرابات حتى القطاع الخاص واصحاب
المؤسسات دخلوا ايضا على خط الاحتجاج وهذا
ينظر ليس فقط شتاء ساخن ولكن شتاء قد يضيء
الى مواجهه لا تحمد عقباها بين السلطه
وبين عموم التونسيين وفي ظل هذه الظروف
الاستثنائيه تعد تونس العده لاجراء
الاستحقاق التشريعيه في انتظار الحصول من
عدمه على قرض من صندوق النقد الدوليه
لانعاش الاقتصاد وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه البرازيل تقترب
من حجز مقعدها في ربع النهائيه على حساب
كوريا الجنوبيه النتيجه حتى الان اربعه
مقابل هدف الكوريون اذن يعني يحفظون بهذا
الهدف الذي سجل قبل قليل الموفدنا الى
الدوحه البزاري يتابع بعد قليل الليث
نعم النتيجه خمسه صفر قبل قليل هنا في
ملعب 9 7 4 في الدوحه التي تقام على على
ارض على ارضه المباراه بين كوريا الجنوبيه
سنتابع معك بعد قليل
هذه الاصوات
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد تقترب في هذه الاثناء
اذا مشاهدينا البرازيل من حجزهم مقعدها في
دوري ربع نهائي في كاس العالم بعد تسجيلها
اربعه اهداف مقابل هدف وحيد حتى الان
لكوريا الجنوبيه حول هذه الاجواء معنا من
الدوحه هذا المفيد العربيه ليث بازاري ليث
اهلا بك يعني من كثره الاهداف الحقيقه
التي سجلتها البرازيل هذه الليله اي هدى
في يسمع يعتقد انه هو هدف للبرازيل
الاجواء عندك
نعم صهيب هذه الاجواء عنا دائما اتعودنا
هون في المباريات في كاس العالم في قطر ان
نستمع الى الاصوات اذا كان الهتاف اكثر من
30 ثانيه فان هناك هدف اكيد ولكن دعني
اتكلم عن ما اشاهد الذي حصل الان قبل ان
استضيف الاشخاص الموجودين هنا اذا اخذنا
الكاميرا جريانسيون في منطقه يوجد الكثير
من البرازيليون الذين يتركون استاد
متاكدون بانهم تاهلوا ولذلك يقومون بترك
استاد او الملعب والتوجه الى اماكن اخر
لاماكن اخرى يعني شاهدنا قبل قليل همم
عائلتين همم خرجوا من من المدخل الرئيسي
للمدخل الجمهور الاستاد وهم طبعا
ينتقلون الى مناطق اخرى في الدوحه وهم
طبعا تاكدوا ان ان ال- ال- البرازيل مؤهله
وهذا كل ما يحصل يعني همم لحظات المباشر
واذا رجعنا على الاشخاص الموجودين هون عنا
من فلسطين من مصر من السعوديه من مصر من
كينيا خلينا نبدا مع السيد هذا لو سمحتوا
ااا سيدي سليمان
ليس الفريق الكيني بلدها ولكن الفريق
البرازيل منذ زمن بعيد انتم شباب عايشين
هون
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم
باذن الله البرازيل والمغرب حضرتك
من اول المونديال ولا بس هلا
قطر هنا ان شاء الله واحضر مباريات باذن
الله بكره ان شاء الله البرتغال راح
احضرها ان شاء الله اذا حصلت تذكره للمغرب
باذن الله مساندين المغرب المغرب حظ
المغربيين كلهم نحن كلنا معاهم والله يكتب
لهم الخير قدام اسبانيا والتاهل للدوره
القادم باذن الله العرب كلهم مع ال-
المغرب
المباراه او المنتخب
كاس العالم وبياخذ النهائي ان شاء الله
ولكن هذه الاجواء التي
فرحه
حماس الممثل العربي الوحيد
انا الاسباني انت لا تسمعني ساكتفي معك
بهذا القدر اذا ليث بزاري مفيد العربيه
الى الدوحه
[موسيقى]
بهذا مشاهدينا تنتهي اخبار الساعه لهذه
الليله شكرا لكم على المشاهده والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]